jair bolsonaro ha convertido la
celebración del bicentenario de brasil
en un acto político gigantesco en busca
de su reelección aquí en copacabana
desde primera hora de la mañana hay
muchos seguidores del presidente que han
venido a apoyarle hay que recordar la
polémica bolsonaro quería un gran acto
parada en plena avenida atlántica pero
el alcalde de río de janiero se negó por
esa razón ha habido simplemente una
parada de naves militares en la bahía de
guanabará y exhibición de las fuerzas
aéreas en los cielos de la ciudad
es una fecha para todos los brasileños
independientemente de su ideología
política de cualquier espectro político
sea de derecha o de izquierda
la cuestión de secuestrar o no la
celebración la bandera los colores
creo que es una cuestión sólo para la
izquierda socialista para los comunistas
ellos también podrían usar los colores
de brasil el verde y el amarillo
deberían pero escogieron no utilizarlos
[Aplausos]
bolsonaro enderezó brasil y sigue
enderezando lo creo que es un hombre
honesto no hay ninguna evidencia contra
él y eso que la izquierda ha buscado
pruebas y no ha encontrado nada malo
contra él él es el único hombre enviado
por dios que va a enderezar brasil
pero ha decidido dar hoy una prueba de
fe
no a decenas de millares de seguidores
principales ciudades de brasil por la
mañana en brasil él dijo que es ymbro
sabe
mismo en portugués que significa
infalible en la cama ya en río de
janeiro se atraso en su discurso atacó
de forma muy velada al tribunal supremo
y optó por un discurso mucho más
conciliador de 17 minutos que mostrarán
un bolsonaro confiante
ante millares de seguidores que
estuvieron todo el día esperándole aquí
en copacabana